hello everyone and welcome to today's
video on introduction to identity and
access management also known as iam
monitoring usage of corporate data and
access to privileged information had
been a daunting task before the advent
of iam
and compassing numerous apis single
sign-on frameworks and data handling
policies iem has established itself as a
key component of every it department
but how does it enforce these rules and
what are the key benefactors of these
policies
what about the advantages of these
frameworks and the workflow of these
systems
we are here today to answer these
questions
let's take a look at some of the topics
to be covered today
we start by learning about iam that is
identity and access management from a
surface level so as to put a clear idea
of what it is
next we cover the general workflow and
process of how iam works
moving on we cover some of the tools
that find the place in an iem framework
and are crucial components
finally we go through some of the
advantages of the iam learning what
makes them a lucrative deal for
organizations
so let's get started by learning about
iam from a surface level perspective
identity and access management or iam is
a set of processes policies and tools
for defining and managing the roles and
access privileges of individual network
entities to a variety of cloud and
on-premise applications
the users can include customers partners
employees devices like computers
smartphones routers etc
the core objective of iem systems is one
digital identity per individual or item
once the digital identity has been
established it must be maintained
modified and monitored throughout each
user's or device's access lifecycle
access and user are two vital iam
concepts
access refers to the actions permitted
to be done by a user like view create or
change a file
users could be employees partners
suppliers contractors or even customers
furthermore employees can be further
segmented based on their roles
iam systems are designed to perform
three key tasks identify authenticate
and authorize
meaning that only the right person
should have access to computers hardware
software apps any it resources etc
for the entry of new users or the
changing of the roles of existing users
the list of access privileges must be up
to date all the time
im functions usually fall under it
departments or sections that handle
cyber security and data
management now that we understand the
importance of iem in today's cyber
security sphere let us understand the
process of this framework
if multiple components that aid this
process let's start by going through
each of them individually
principle is an entity that can perform
actions on an aws resource or any cloud
management system
a user a role or an application can be a
principle
it's always the principal who raises a
concern to access or modify data on
servers serving as the first point of
contact in the im workflow
authentication is the process of
confirming the identity of the principal
trying to access the product
the principal must provide such
credentials or required keys for
authentication
this step can be further enhanced by
multiple authentication factors and
geologs among other things
once the identity is confirmed the
principal has the ability to view the
data behind the wall of security take
the necessary steps
when it comes to requests a principal
then sends a request to the cloud
management system specifying the action
and which resource should perform it
in this step the user can ask to modify
delete edit or affect other users in
this particular bucket of organization
by changing the data or the information
when it comes to authorization it
carries out the rest of an organization
identity and access management processes
once the user has been authenticated
users are granted authorizations
according to their role at an
organization the practice is referred to
as the role-based access control or rbec
authorizations determine a role's
resources and level of access in the
network
these items may include systems
applications file shares printers and
more
for example an accounting department
employee who regularly works with
payroll software must be authorized to
do such if authentication resembles a
passport these are the things your
digital identity can access with it
while authentication is fully
straightforward
authorizations and their management are
far more challenging authorizations
consist of complex set of rules and
policies and groups which are permitted
explicitly configured per user account
with the working of im frameworks out of
the way lets cover some of the tools
that these systems work on
sso is an iem tool that enables a user
to log into one organization's
properties and automatically be logged
into a design set of other properties
for example when you log into google
you're automatically logged into your
gmail and your youtube accounts
similarly for users single sign-on
reduces fiction since they don't have to
keep track of different credentials for
every application
for organizations sso helps in
collecting valuable insights about user
behavior and preferences since it tags
them as they move from one application
to another connected by one single login
next is multi-factor authentication or
mfa
implementing multi-factor authentication
is crucial to protect your
organization's data from malicious
intrusions and virtually every im
platform offers some form of mfa
however it is equally crucial to
customize mfa with the appropriate level
of security
for example in business to consumer
scenarios you need to consider ux and
try not to create unnecessary friction
for users who don't want to be subjected
to heightened scrutiny every time they
log in
for workforce i am you may want a more
stringent mfa since the consequences of
an unauthorized party gaining access to
your private network can be so
devastating
a modern iem solution will allow you to
implement mfa only when it's needed this
can be accomplished to set up
authentication or adaptive
authentication in which users only
trigger mfa if they are trying to access
sensitive data or their behavior is
flagged as risky
in the past few years identity has
become the preferred gateway for hackers
to break into systems brute force
attacks credential stuffing attacks and
even highly targeted phishing campaigns
are all attempts by hackers to break in
through a company's front door which is
the login box
there are multiple ways im systems can
help detect and mitigate these malicious
attacks im solutions detect attacks by
monitoring signals such as the velocity
of traffic detection of login patterns
that differ from a user's routine use of
a breached password use of devices and
ip addresses with a poor reputation
among other things
these are some of the most widely used
tools when it comes to im frameworks but
why do we go through setting up so many
tools and firewalls
lets go through some of the advantages
of using im systems in both corporate
and consumer environments
im solution helps identify and mitigate
security risks
you can use iem to identify policy
violations or remove inappropriate
access privileges without having to
search through multiple distributed
systems you can also leverage iem to
ensure that security measures are in
place to meet regulatory and auditing
requirements
iem provides a common platform for
access and identity management
information you can apply the same
security policies across all the
operating systems and devices used by
the organization
the imframework can help you enforce
policies related to user authentication
privileges and validation and attend to
the privileged creep problems
iem simplifies sign up and user
management processes for application
owners end users and system
administrators
it makes it simple to provide and manage
access and promotes user satisfaction
im services can also lower operating
costs using federated identity services
means you no longer need local
identities for external users
this makes application administration
easier
cloud-based im services can reduce the
need to buy and maintain on-premise
infrastructure
hope you learned something new today
if you have any questions feel free to
let us know in the comment section below
and we'll get back to you as soon as
possible
subscribe to our channel for more info
video videos like this and thank you for
watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here